JASON SILVA: What's up
"Shots of Awe" fans?
Jason Silva here,
letting you know
that July is creativity
month here on "Shots of Awe",
which means that every video we
post will be about creativity.
It'll be about exploring
that liminal trance states,
that magical borderland
between dreams and reality,
that space in which
we connect the dots.
We'll fall down the rabbit hole,
we'll fall through the looking
glass, it will be amazing.
So make sure you
subscribe here on YouTube,
or like my page on Facebook.
And of course, click on
the link in the description
to see the playlist
on creativity.
This is Jason Silva.
Thanks for watching
"Shots of Awe".
I love you guys.
Peace.